99 I started at Queens University taught,
okay,
you were protested or testers
interrupted your talk at the beginning.
I believe you were spurred to them as
narcissistic for infringing upon the
rights of the people that
were there to hear you speak.
They were taking that away from them.
Um,
in our country.
Just recently,
we had an unarmed man
shot in his back yard.
20 Times.
People protested that
they shut down highways,
um,
being infringed on the rights of people
to use those highways because they
wanted to draw attention to
this really horrible incident.
I'm asking you when is it okay
to protest and in your own mind,
how do you see a successful protest?
You protest
[inaudible]
it's okay to protest when you're
wanting to take responsibility for the
consequences.
No one [inaudible]
protests.
Dave take absolutely no responsibility
whatsoever for the consequences of the
Raj.
And so I think it's
mostly cheap virtually.
Now,
that doesn't mean that there
isn't time diamond protest.
I mean,
I protested,
I suppose the one nine,
eight,
nine video.
Well,
I was a form of protest.
It was more of a refusal,
but I was perfectly willing to take
the consequences of what I did.
And I put myself in a
situation where that was high,
no problem.
So let's see if you tell,
it was just with the book called skin,
skin in the game,
we're helping clients,
this is some detail,
you should only trust people who are
putting themselves on the line when they,
when they make a recommendation.
And so the problem with protests
that if there is anything invalid,
the moment protest,
the problem with protest
as far as I can tell,
is that it's become the only avenue to
public virtue that seems to be acceptable
in our society.
And I think it's [inaudible].
I hate to lose.
The students are taught by their
professors to be activists.
It's like when did the activists
become like a profession?
As long as it's,
I don't know what to say about it either.
It's
pathological hanging
from the 1960s is really
all right.
Under that you have a
tremendous amount of breath.
Here we go.
Wow.
That was already
your whole life.
Okay.
So,
um,
we have,
I guess what I'll be charitable and call
a dialogue going on about guns right
now.
Um,
and mental health,
I guess it's also tied in with it.
And you mentioned that,
um,
essentially that the people that commit
these kind of massacres that we're
seeing are,
it's addapp determined malevolence um,
and it seems to me that,
you know,
we're looking for simple
answers to simple questions.
Um,
and what I'm seeing,
and I guess kind of the preface a
little bit is I believe that the second
amendment is not just to help us protect
ourselves against those kinds of people
who would do us harm,
but also to protect against tyranny.
[inaudible]
hospital could get the simple answers
to simple questions if these people are
determined to be 11 on tend
to commit acts of destruction.
So what do you think that we can
realistically do about the situation?
Okay.
Well the first thing is,
is that I think it's just a state to set
up a society where the only people that
get to be dangerous,
perpendicular,
who worked for the government
[inaudible].
I think that's the reason I say to is
because I think that was more dangerous.
That's great.
Now what can we do about it?
Well,
I see the bounce shootings
as a psychological trauma.
Fundamentally it's a multifaceted problem.
I mean,
the first thing is,
is that there's a fair bit of narcissism
driving into like pathological
narcissism because the people
who do the amount of shootings,
they're all aware of one another and
it's a competition which established
competition.
Each one tries to outdo the last one
and it's not like they're aching or,
and they follow,
they follow,
they're informed about such things.
They're dwelling on it.
And so they found a loophole in the press
essentially ranked because they found
a pathway to easy notoriety.
And a lot of the fantasizing that goes on,
it's like the fantasizing that the
proceeds out of the level of suicide.
So on 11,
suicide is one that you commit when you're
trying to take revenge on people that
you think of wrongdoing,
like your family.
And then you have a fantasy about
you at the funeral in your coffin.
You know,
looking so pure white and
everyone that's ever wrong view,
crying their eyes out and be uh,
you know,
feeling deep regretted
how they groaned you.
Right?
So that's a,
there's a fantasy that
goes along with that.
There's anything,
uh,
fantasies it's a kid without that goes
along with the school shooter types.
You know,
they,
they think about their post death cells
cause they usually shoot themselves
because that's another way of
showing cause he fake here.
Here's a,
here's a mystery.
If you're going to shoot yourself,
why don't you do that before you shoot?
Because they see other people and just
say if everyone that trouble right,
if you're,
if you're out for your own demise,
why go other dragging me some
other people loan with you?
You have to contend with them.
Well,
it's more dramatic because you're,
you're,
what you're trying to manifest in the
world is that proclamation that life
itself is contemptible even yours.
Right?
And so you shoot about general other
people to make them a whole contemptible
point,
but they do it off.
But then what's underlying that is this
post death fantasy about how now you've
meet Cory,
it's you have $100 million
worth of free publicity.
Everybody knows your name if you're
at the peak of the evil hierarchy,
something like that.
And the press plays right into that.
And I'm shaking my finger at the press.
It's a very complicated problem because
even if the main street press decided
that they weren't going to
save the names of the shooters,
which would be a very good idea,
I don't think that would stop the
damage from being pumped facades.
Okay.
So it's a complicated technical problem.
I would say off the psychological front
12 that's the sort of discussion we're
having tonight.
We need to have a discussion about why
it's wrong to take malevolent revenge
because there's reasons for it,
but it's wrong.
It's like you can understand it.
Well,
you see there's outpourings of sympathy
often for the school shooter types.
All,
they must have been terribly bullied.
It's like,
well,
how many of you were terribly
bullied when it's like 50% of you?
You know,
it's like you don't go out
and shoot up a high school,
you know who sold it.
It's it.
It's not.
Yes,
perhaps they were bullied,
but that doesn't justify the actions.
We need to have a serious discussion about
why it doesn't justify their actions.
And it's something like you don't get
to multiply your misery and inflicted on
the world.
That's wrong even though
it's understandable,
it's wrong.
And you know,
you'd think that maybe we could have
a serious discussion about this is the
schools,
but like,
yeah,
right.
The problem that would happen
is like zero but don't.
But online you can have the discussion.
I mean,
part of the reasons that people had been.
Please,
I suppose with my lectures.
Oh,
they're very strange things to be pleased
about this because I do address these
things rather bluntly.
It's like life is hard and people
have a massive capacity for evil,
and it's no wonder that everyone's angry.
What's your point?
And to make it worse,
that's your plan.
Well,
that's just not a year.
That's his weak and the pathological.
It's pathetic.
It's cowardly.
It's not to be countenanced.
It's nothing too.
Amen.
There's nothing heroic about,
it's wrong.
It's wrong,
because it makes everything into hell.
And so you need to have serious
conversation about that.
Tonight is a serious
So yeah.
[inaudible].